Vor vier milliarden jahren geschah etwas wirklich unfassbar ist ein riesiger gesteinsbrocken aus dem all
Rammte die erde und was genau geschah dann das hat es ja nicht
So ganz klar jetzt hat der geophysiker psylock vielleicht die idee was damals
dramatisches wahrscheinlich passierte und die folgen jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Wie entstand eigentlich der mond eines ist klar bei einer unglaublichen katastrophe bisher war man der ansicht dass
Er quasi aus der erde damals herausgesprengt wurde aber so ganz passt diese vorstellung einfach nicht das mondgestein und das der erde
die beiden die sind ziemlich homogen zu
Einheitliche jetzt hat der geophysiker psylock eine neue idee als der brocken die erde traf wurde die erde seiner ansicht nach
Komplett zerstört was übrig blieb war eine wolke aus gas und flüssigem gestein
unglaublich heiß aber kein planet mehr die erde war
Komplett zerstört worden so meint er es dauerte dann nur noch ein paar hundert jahre bis sich die wolke wieder verdichtete
Doch etwas war anders als vorher ein kleiner teil der materie bildete einen eigenen klumpen den mond mit
Dieser idee können viele probleme gelöst werden und lockert es nachgerechnet
genau
so
funktioniert es in seiner simulation danach hat sich nach dem zusammenstoß eine sogenannte sinne sehr gebildet an sich schnell drehende donath aus
Flüssigem oder zu staub zerstört und gestein damit wäre erklärt warum die erde nur einen montag warum
er den gesamten drehimpuls des erde mond systems trägt und vor allem warum die isotopenzusammensetzung
Des mond gesteins mit dem der erde nahezu identisch ist und das ist nur möglich wenn dieser riesige brocken
Sich komplett mit der erde und dem mond vermischt hat was nur geht wenn sich als zwischenstadium einem
Semester gebildet hat und noch eine besonderheit des mondgestein es passt zu dieser hypothese
Flüchtige elemente wie kalium und natrium können
Im außenbereich einer solch solchen es ja ins all entweichen das mondgestein würde weniger von diesen elementen enthalten und genau das ist der fall
Noch ist die fachwelt sehr skeptisch aber
Bisher ist das die einzige die wirklich alles erklären kann nur eine solche nächstes jahr wurde noch
Nie beobachtet vielleicht wird ja das james webb teleskop ein solches phänomen dann bald finden allerdings wird sich nach neuesten meldungen der stadt
Verschieden was wirklich sehr schade ist geldmangel
Ist wohl der grund wenn ihr als erstes neues zu diesem thema und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer
bei, whatsapp das geht hier mit diesem linklink dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert
er könnte die über mich in der redaktion vom klick zum mitmachen und mehr themen vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen
Und somit bestimmen was hierbei klicks um passiert der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken ja und natürlich
nicht das abo und
Genau die glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken 1000 raketen, zu mars ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran